designing videogame characters looks fun
and must be easy right well after you
design one or two original characters
ideas can be difficult to come by
imagine working on MK armageddon which
has 62 playable characters when you run
out of original concepts don't worry
just pick your favorite celebrity here
are six video game characters based on
real-life people and by the way we mean
celebrities so don't expect to find your
mid Dave on this list as I've already
mentioned Mortal Kombat let's start
there do you recognize Johnny Cage well
he strongly based on jean-claude van
Damme he was huge in the 80s and 90s due
to his martial art prowess and
fantastical dancing
the studio that became nether realms was
working on a blood spot film tie-in but
the image rights hit problems so the
character was renamed Johnny Cage but
kept John Claude Van Dam's moveset such
as punching people in the groin whilst
doing the splits Street Fighter 2 was a
great game I'll never forget those two
men dancing in front of a building
before 1 Sucker Punch is the other in
the face but I digress
do you remember the character Balrog he
was an african-american boxer you fought
in the latter stages of the tournament
and it doesn't take a genius to see that
he's based on Mike Tyson in the game's
original release the character is named
M by some Capcom in fear of being sued
switched Balrog and M Bisons names to
allow a release in the u.s. in Street
Fighter Alpha 3 Balrog even threatens to
bite off the players ear and not so
subtle reference to the Tyson Holyfield
fight in 1997 over to another classic
which has spanned decades Metroid it was
a shock to everyone when Samus Aran
first removed her helmet to reveal she
was in fact a woman back then heroic
females weren't widely considered for
starring roles in many forms of media
luckily times have changed and female
protagonists are given a fair share of
videogame outings but that's a video for
another time Samus was based on another
action survivalist from the movie alien
yep
Sigourney Weaver but as graphical
capabilities improved attention to
detail became more apparent and the
design team decided to base Samus on the
actress Kim Basinger you may remember
her from such films as Tim Burton's
Batman where she played Vicki Vale she
was also in LA Confidential and she was
even and bomb girl back in the 80s the
next character based on a real-life
celeb was met with controlled outrage
from the actress in question The Last of
Us asks you to chaperone a young girl
across the u.s. the character in
question is Ellie when the character was
first shown back in 2011 everybody
believed she was a licensed recreation
of the actress
Paige but in fact she was completely
oblivious to the character and had
already signed up to appear in another
game beyond two souls after a rather
public debacle the luster has adapted
the character of Ellie to look a little
less like Paige and a little more like
her voice actress Ashley Johnson who is
this character is it dr. Robotnik or dr.
Eggman I'll let you decide for yourself
but to me he'll always be dr. Robotnik
did you know that this super villain
from Sega's Sonic series was based on
u.s. President Theodore Roosevelt in
certain poses the likeness is uncanny
but at this point it's uncertain if
Theodore Roosevelt imprisoned animals
and had a blue hedgehog as his nemesis
but I'm pretty sure he did we've made it
to the top of the list and it's the one
and only Bruce Lee if you're a gamer I
personally guarantee you have witnessed
his reincarnation somewhere on your
travels probably the most obvious use of
Bruce Lee's likeness is found in Tekken
where a character named law looks
identical to lead martial law with him
his moveset is the same and he even
wears the same yellow jumpsuit
synonymous with Bruce Lee this isn't
just Tekken who rips off Bruce Lee we
found it in numerous places such as
Mortal Kombat with the character named
Liu Kang
Kim dragon from SNK street fighters fair
long fatal fury han foo rock from Naruto
on ek gear from tenchu there's even a
Pokemon named hitman Lee Wei Shen from
Sleeping Dogs Maxie in the game series
Soul Calibur Yan Li from dead or alive
Kenshiro from Fist of the North Star
kr meteor from chemin Rider Dragon champ
from super punch-out League of Legends
dragon fists with a costume for Lee sin
and the man himself even shows up in the
UFC these days the term Bruce plication
has been coined to help record all the
uses of Bruce Lee over the years and the
list seems endless so that was our list
of videogame characters based on real
people have we missed any let us know
below if this video has helped you pass
the time or maybe it was even
entertaining please drop us a like and
consider subscribing
I imagine thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
you
you